[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 8 décembre bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition
du 7 8 les inviter celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département des
yvelines aujourd'hui vous entendrez à
sandrine grand gang c'est la première
secrétaire fédérale des yvelines du
parti socialiste elle reviendra sur la
primaire de la gauche le renoncement de
françois hollande candidature de manuel
valls rumeurs autour de vincent peillon
comment sa formation en vue d'acheter de
l'avenir etienne pinte ancien député
maire de versailles est aujourd'hui
engagée dans la lutte contre la pauvreté
nous avons rencontré le président du
conseil national de la lutte contre
l'exclusion lors d'une réunion dans les
yvelines et puis hugo geslin c'est le
réalisateur de la comédie dramatique de
main tout commence avec omar sy il est
venu à défendre son film lors d'une
projection à montigny le bretonneux ce
sera la fin de cette émission
bonsoir sandrine granby d'être la
première secrétaire fédérale du parti
socialiste donc dans le département des
yvelines après à l'ump aujourd'hui et
c'est au tour de votre formation
politique d'être au coeur de l'actualité
avec l'organisation de cette primaire
est déjà une dizaine de candidats qui
sont déclarées ou qui sont pressentis
jean luc bennahmias gérard filoche
benoît hamon marie noëlle lienemann
arnaud montebourg françois de rugy
manuel valls sans doute vincent peillon
également sylvia pinel le fondateur en
revanche du mouvement nouvelle donne et
pierre larrouturou a été recalé
aujourd'hui par les instances du parti
socialiste tous ces noms je les ai cité
juste pour vous poser une simple
question est-ce que c'est preuve d'une
vitalité aujourd'hui démocratique au
sein de la gauche du parti socialiste ou
au contraire est-ce que c'est inquiétant
pour l'avenir
là on est dans la phase
tout le monde deux noms ceux des
candidatures mais ce qui sera
intéressant c'est de voir l'industrie
qui ira réellement jusqu'au bout
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
systèmes de parrainage et donc je pense
que le 15 décembre
votre liste là sera déjà beaucoup plus
raccourcis donc on attendra peut-être de
devoir qui est réellement en capacité en
fait d'avoir un soutien qui justifie en
fait sa présence dans les primaires
j'aimerais qu'on revient tout de même
sur la candidature de vincent peillon
probable candidature de vincent peillon
député européen ancien ministre de
l'éducation il a disparu de la vie
politique pendant presque deux ans
depuis qu'il a quitté le ministère
d'éducation
qu'il revienne que son nom reviennent ce
que c'est une bonne chose il a disparu
mais en réalité les députés européens on
vous l'avait dit donc sauf que
malheureusement ce qui se passe au
niveau européen en france n'intéresse
pas grand monde alors que l'essentiel de
notre avenir s'ils jouent donc ça serait
intéressant qu'on a une autre vision de
l'europe
après sur sa possible candidature déjà
on verra effectivement si c'est une
réalité et ça correspond je conseille
aussi un désir d'un dans une famille
pauvre femme tendance politique on va
dire qui est un petit peu orpheline
depuis que françois hollande a décidé de
ne pas se représenter
on s'est parlé de cette ce mandat au
parlement européen journal marianne qui
révèle tout de même que vincent peillon
n'est pas le plus assidu à toutes les
réunions il a été présent à seulement
plus de la moitié des réunions de sa
commission des affaires étrangères je
tenais tout mais aussi à le souligner
parce qu'il a d'autres activités pas
uniquement politique là des prix quand
même un peu un peu de recul mais cette
candidature vincent peillon qui se dit
piloté par martine aubry pour embêter un
petit peu manuel valls d'une réalité est
ce que c'est un jeu actuel c'est pas je
crois que c'est vraiment abandonné
on voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
ligne tranché au sein de
la gauche et du ps et la question c'est
pour les différentes militants c'est qui
peut incarner au mieux la ligne que je
représente qui qu'ils me parlent et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans cette
période où les uns et les autres
cherchent un petit peu finalement
qu'est-ce qui s'il n'y a pas de candidat
naturel en réalité la situation que l'on
vit aujourd'hui c'est le résultat d'un
constat d'ailleurs que le président de
la république a fait lui-même qu'il n'y
a pas de candidat naturel
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait des
primaires aussi serment donné pour créer
des dynamiques au tour de ceux qui
peuvent potentiellement porter nos
couleurs à la présidentielle en 2017
le choix justement de françois hollande
de ne pas se présenter pour un second
mandat
elle s'était aussi c'est comme ça qu'il
l'a présenté aux françaises et oreo
français c'était afin de maintenir
l'unité de la gauche aussi pas de créer
de la division sur la division parce que
pour l'instant c'est réussi où ça sent
plutôt ratée lorsqu'on entend tout c'est
pourtant c'est trop tôt pour le dire
je pense qu'on est vraiment dans la
phase de doute où va se décanter en fait
et on a vécu ça de la même manière avec
les républicains pour leurs prix mais on
emmenait ya beaucoup plus de candidats
henri guaino dans département était
candidat puis finalement il n'a pas été
enfin voilà donc on a tous ces éléments
après la décision de françois hollande
elle est tout à fait respectable et tout
le monde l'a saluée mais c'est aussi le
constat de shilin qu'il n'était pas lui
en capacité de faire ce rassemblement
qui est nécessaire donc et qui aurait
été difficile donc après sa queue
électeurs de gauche est invitée à venir
se prononcer sur quelle est la personne
justement qu'il considère comme pouvant
mieux incarner sait quel est votre
candidat
alors moi j'ai deux casquettes si vous
voulez j'ai la casquette de premier
fédéral à ce titre comme cambadélis
on n'est pas censé prendre parti dans
l'organisation du vote des primaires
dire que la fédération organisera de
manière équitable pour lui l'ensemble
des candidats bien sûr que tout ira en
tant que première fédérale dans la
gestion de tout au quotidien on va dire
je
je serai tout à fait neutre après à
titre personnel tout le monde sait que
je suis engagé auprès de benoît mais je
ne l'utiliserai pas mon bon le rôle que
les militants m'ont confié pour faire la
campagne de benoît hamon néanmoins vous
pensez que benoît hamon peut-être le
françois fillon la gauche c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui que lui-même se présentant
au moins il est troisième dans les
premiers sondages qui commence à être
être fait aujourd'hui derrière manuel
valls errements ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il va forcément étonné parce que il
est sur une autre façon de faire qui est
de prier vraiment le fond et son projet
des mois qu'ils qui déroule dans les
réunions publiques sont son projet et je
crois qu'on a besoin de ça aussi les
randonnées en adhère on n'adhère pas
mais c'est de se positionner par rapport
à des idées et par rapport des
propositions
donc c'est je pense que c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on peut réconcilier les
français avec la politique si c'est pas
des marionnettes ou c'est pas des c'est
pas des simplement des hommes ou des
femmes c'est d'abord des projets qui est
comporte
quoi qu'il arrive à l'issue de cette
primaire la gauche aura tranché sur sa
ligne directrice et on en saura un petit
peu plus ce que ça veut dire que le
parti socialiste après la primaire sera
mort et qu'il faudra recomposer le
paysage de la gauche non on aura
forcément noté un paysage qu'inattendue
iront vers ajustements lequel est lequel
il est beaucoup va dépendre aussi de la
réussite ou non de cette primaire dire
que si on a une vraie dynamique avec
meriem de peur cette primaire serait ce
que sur la teneur des échanges la jebba
ce nom parce que le débat en france et
n'a pas encore des rancoeurs quand même
bien sûr mais le débat oui mais le débat
il est là de toute façon donc après c
est ce qu on l'organisé ou pas et le les
primaires ça donne un cadre justement
pour organiser les débats il faut avoir
des règles et la dernière fois en 2011
tout le monde avait dit que ça serait
une catastrophe ça a été
l' inverse il vrai vrai engouement et
derrière on a une belle dynamique
donc je pense que tout ce qui permet
d'avoir des règles communes et un cadre
nous permet ensuite de débattre parfois
c'est compliqué parfois c'est un pas
taper trop fort pour réconcilier tout ce
qu'il ya des élections derrière pour les
je pense que tant que ça reste sur
justement d'un problème idéologique et
de fond et qu'on ne vit pas sur des
attaques de personnes
c'est pas un problème en termes
pratiques d'un à question comment ça va
s'organiser cette primaire de la gauche
dans le département déjà bas on est là
en train de faire de faire remonter le
national les bureaux de vote d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire à l'ensemble des
maires de droite qui traînent des pieds
qui ne nous donne pas de réponse alors
qu'ils ont prêté des bureaux de vote
il ya quelques semaines pour dans les
mêmes circonstances pour pour la droite
vraiment ça serait sympa de donner des
réponses sur les demandes qui sont les
nôtres qui sont des domaines assez
raisonnable de bureaux de vote de lieu
de bureau doit donc un certain nombre de
villes qui fait pas donné les noms mais
qui n'est pour l'instant refuse de nous
répondre tout simplement on ne sait un
exercice démocratique donc on a
normalement dans le nord même une
centaine on aura une centaine de bureaux
tout petit peu moins que la dernière
fois mais à peu près dans le même
sillage et l'idée c'est que les citoyens
qui ont même l'impression que c'est
quelque chose qui organisait même pas
parler partie puisque la plainte qui
vont même dans les mairies pour demander
où il vote comme si c'était quelque
chose devenue habituelle
il faut qu'on puisse leur permettent
dans des bonnes conditions de se
prononcer et cette primaire ce sera 22
janvier pour le deux premiers tours 29
janvier pour le deuxième
merci 6e gang c'est une nouvelle
question qui agite la société française
depuis des mois faut-il ou non
accueillir les migrants les réfugiés sur
notre sol élus habitants associations se
déchire sur la question sur le rôle que
doit jouer la france il ya quelques
jours une réunion se tenait avec
plusieurs intervenants c'était dans le
département des yvelines parmi les
intervenants justement etienne pinte
l'ancien député maire de versailles et
c'est l'actuel président du conseil
national des politiques de lutte contre
l'exclusion sociale et la pauvreté et
coûté le set au micro de nicolas kirilow
its
c'est vrai que nous accueillons un
certain nombre de réfugiés mais sans
commune mesure nous ne sommes pas envahi
sans commune mesure est beaucoup
d'autres pays qui reçoivent qui
accueille
des millions des millions de personnes
et donc j'estime que la france pays des
droits de l'homme et des citoyens le
pays des libertés qui a toujours été son
tour une image en quelque sorte
d'accueil de l'étranger de celui qui
réfugiés de celui qui est expulsé de
celui qui est en souffrance eh bien nous
devons répondre à cette tradition et
nous avons les moyens
le pays est l'un des plus riches du
monde 5e ou 6e accueillir de façon
sereine et pacifique
ces migrants qui choisissent la france
il faut reconnaître y en a beaucoup qui
ne choisissent pas la france mais qui
choisit beaucoup d'autres pays
je pense que dans leur for intérieur les
français ne sont pas je dirais que c'est
nos forums
simplement je pense que la situation
économique et sociale fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une certaine
crainte
peut-être une certaine peur il faut
quand même jamais oublier que dans les
années 75 80 nous avons accueilli 120
milles boat people du vietnam du
cambodge du laos
quand en 1962 nous avons accueilli plus
d'un million de rapatriés d'algérie et
tout ça s'est fait sans problème sans
difficulté donc nous avons je dirais une
histoire d'accueil
encore faut-il effectivement qu'on ne la
subit aujourd'hui et personnellement je
pense que nous avons les moyens de
l'assumer pacifiquement je pense qu'il
faut faire beaucoup plus d'information
de pédagogie de rappeler l'histoire est
également de dire que nous sommes dans
une dans un pays dont je dirais l'équité
la justice n'est pas aussi parfaite
qu'on pourrait l'imaginer je n'oublions
quand même jamais que dans ce pays il ya
20 milliards de fraudes sociales igas
entre 60 et 80 milliards de fraude
fiscale
donc nous avons les moyens me
semble-t-il jeudi répondra à toutes les
difficultés à la pauvreté à l'exclusion
la précarité et l accueil des réfugiés à
condition qu'on en prenne les moyens et
que véritablement on arrive à actu et
ses fléaux de la fraude
le film est dans les salles françaises
depuis à ce mercredi demain tout
commence avec le natif de trappes omar
sy
l'équipe du film est venu à saint
quentin en yvelines à défendre justement
la sortie de ce long métrage miquel et
demi d'eau en a profité pour échanger
avec le réalisateur hugo gère alors je
suis maintenant avec hugo geslin le
réalisateur du film donc demain tout
commence hugo geslin ce film c'est votre
deuxième si j'ai bien compris comment
voile appréhendez-vous cette sortie à
battre eh bien écoutez on a fait tout le
taf maintenant ça fait déjà moi j'ai
fait mon talent de real pendant un bon
temps une année et demie et puis
maintenant
et maintenant je me concentre sur la
tournée en province on a présenté le
film dans beaucoup de villes en france
et puis on a fait des avant-premières un
peu partout dont ici à skywest et c'est
formidable parce que c'est
l'aboutissement du travail s'est
rencontré le public le montrer aux gens
à voir le vrai ressenti des gens quand
ils sortent du film et c'est
exceptionnel à entendre parce que les
gens sortent du film avec le sourire aux
lèves et en même temps avec les yeux
embués de larmes donc c'est un mélange
d'émotions ils ont ri en même temps ils
ont envie de deux comiques dramatiques
on a un petit peu la sensation dans ce
film exactement bas henry et et on est
ému comme dans la vie et au final c'est
ce qui est le plus intéressant au cinéma
chante les plus grandes comédies du
cinéma sont souvent teintées d'une
histoire dramatique les plus grandes
nous on s'est beaucoup inspiré du kid de
chaplin de la vie est belle de binic
sont des films où il ya une histoire
derrière très profonde mais où on rit de
bon coeur et le mélange des genres comme
ça me plaît beaucoup et omar sy il est
commandant ci pourquoi vous l'avez
choisi ben omar il est
c'est une rencontre génial parce que
c'est un acteur très très qui apprend
énormément qui a envie de de
s'intéresser à tous les autres
personnages du film qui est très
généreux dans sa manière d'aborder le
film est l'histoire et son personnage et
les autres donc en fait on est dans un
partage permanent une confiance mutuelle
une envie de travailler tous les deux et
avec les autres partenaires du film
donc c'est un acteur qui a aussi accepté
d'être dans sa zone de confort un petit
peu parce qu'il est drôle
une grande partie du film est en même
temps d'oser aller dans des parties plus
profonde plus émouvante où il les boules
hersant parce que omar a osé mettre sa
pudeur de côté par moment dans le film
et voilà un peu laissé tomber le masque
par moment et donc offrir aux
spectateurs des moments extrêmement
bouleversant d'acteurs qui sont pour moi
des cadeaux quoi et sa personnalité
fonctionne très bien avec celle de
gloria on voit une certaine alchimie
entre sur wii le film west s'en trouvait
au marais gloria je suis hyper content
c'est de la chance et puis après on la
provoque aussi un peu ils se ressemblent
en fait omar et gloria parce que ils ont
tous les deux cette capacitéà simplement
sourire pour qu'une pièce s'illumine et
omar on le sait tous il est comme ça à
gloria le même trait de caractère
quelque part elle sourit et ça fait un
bien fou à tout le monde donc déjà il
était très lié rien que par ça et puis
après on mar s'est beaucoup occupée
d'elle pour lui la mettre à l'aise sur
le plateau et c est moi je me suis
occupé d'elle dans son jeu et au final
c'est un super un super duo
merci beaucoup et hugo demain on a plus
de feuilles on n'a plus rien c'était la
fin appliqués les filles je suis son
grand truc
voilà hippiques et les fiches sur le
plateau aussi piqué les fiches à son
habitude à londres et piquer les fiches
des nanas des nounous de la dass qui
s'était les nounous de la dass il les
aimait pas trop où elle était énervée
il leur piquer leur compte c'était
génial en tout cas le film sort ce
mercredi 7 décembre
merci c'est la fin de cette suite les
invités rendez vous lundi pour une
nouvelle édition aux horaires habituels
les replays sur notre site internet
excellente soirée
[Musique]